Thank You Irene dr. David pulla is a
physicist whose research focuses
primarily on finding efficient effective
methods to protect quantum information
and this is of course in anticipation of
the quantum computing revolution that's
already begun where quantum computing
devices will change the face of
computation as we know it protecting
information in that area is not
surprisingly going to be as much of a
challenge as it is today and the fact
that CFR provides opportunities for
young researchers to mix with
experienced members in their field led
dr. poulan to a situation a while ago
rarely afforded young researchers at a
CFR meeting he said some provocative
things about quantum mechanics which
prompted a challenge from a Nobel
laureate I wasn't there
dr. Pula apparently responded directly
and survived and he's now co-director of
the quantum information science program
please welcome dr. Davila
I'm also off Thank You J for the
introduction so I'm gonna describe to
you what my day in the office looks like
so yeah so when I come in my office and
let's say I don't have any pressing
obligations I like to just stand at the
board and scribble some equations and
these help me come up with new quantum
software so this is what my board looked
like earlier this week in this example I
was I was considering a very common task
in machine learning called stochastic
gradient descent we're using a lot of
computer power to solve that particular
problem currently I was trying to figure
out if this problem could benefit from a
quantum computer if we could accelerate
this and I failed I haven't succeeded
but you know that I have a couple of
other strict tricks down my sleeve and
and this is just one of many problems
that keep me busy but over the years I
have designed a few quantum algorithms a
few piece of quantum software that
should enable a future quantum computer
to solve certain computational problems
in a time that is very reasonable
but that currently cannot be solving
with the world's largest supercomputer
so if we succeed one day in building a
quantum computer some of the software I
came up with could be used to understand
some complex molecular reaction or maybe
some piece of quantum material or
advanced material and these in turn you
know could turn into new drug design or
new energy transport I don't know and
honestly I don't really care you see
when I do research I'm not motivated by
these potential applications I just want
to understand the fundamental power that
quantum mechanics offers in terms of
computing and sometimes I work on a
problem and I realize that this problem
cannot possibly benefit from a quantum
computational speed up and this might be
surprising to you but in terms of you
know like personal fulfillment this is
equally rewarding as finding a new
application because in both case I
learned something new about
quantum mechanics so I think this is
possibly the hallmark of intellectual
freedom it's having the the luxury or
the freedom or the privilege of asking a
question without a priori any preference
or what the answer should be we just
want to know the answer so of course
coming up with new quantum software new
quantum algorithms requires some
technical skills and knowledge you need
to understand how a quantum computer
operates and and what are the the
underlying logic of a quantum quantum
information but I think that by far the
most important ingredient is creative
thinking so you have to take a problem
that we use computers to solve and
understand the mathematical structure of
it and try to understand how you can
grab this problem and make it amenable
to a quantum computer so so in fact the
idea the creative thinking is not only
important today but it's the very idea
of building a quantum computer began
when a few very marginal researchers had
to had the courage of asking a very bold
question the cursor the question they
asked is the following how can quantum
mechanics quantum mechanics is this very
counterintuitive theory that explains
the atomic and subatomic world so how
can quantum mechanics change the way in
which we exchange and process
information so to understand just how
crazy this question is you need to know
that quantum mechanics had always been
restricted to the atomic scale okay you
don't need a quote you don't need
quantum mechanics to explain how a
tennis ball would bounce around or how
airplanes fly these are explained by
Newtonian classical mechanics so
suggesting that a human-scale system
like a computer could utilize that the
strange features of the quantum universe
was delusional when it was first
suggested in the 1980s yet today we
have major corporation government and
venture capitalists investing billions
of dollars to build a quantum computer
this picture shows IBM's latest attempt
you can even play with it you could
access it on the cloud if you'd like so
of course these industrial players are
primarily interested in harnessing and
harvesting sorry the tremendous
computational power of quantum
information but they also recognized
that without intellectual freedom this
power would never have been unleashed
okay
so organizations like CFR help us stay
vigilant and at protecting our right to
ask very tricky and risky questions and
our c4 program the quantum information
science program has been largely shaped
by another very risky question the
question is what do we learn about
fundamental physics by thinking about
physical systems whether it's an
airplane
this remote or a black hole or what not
as an information processing unit so
this might may sounds like a strange
question and it deserves explanation so
of course we're used to think of
information as something immaterial
think about the password to my
smartphone this has nothing to do with
physics does it but the reality is that
any information requires a physical
system whether it's my brain my
harddrive in my phone or ink on a piece
of paper there can be no information
without physical support and this has
consequences so to give you a simple
example you know that no physical body
can travel faster than the speed of
light therefore a consequence is that
you cannot send information information
cannot be transmitted faster than the
speed of light because information needs
to be supported by a physical system so
this is an example of how the laws of
physics impose constraints on the laws
and the rules of information but what we
like to do now is turn this picture
around and say how do the rules of
information processing
affect the universe in which we live the
upshot of this is that information is
universal so if the if you discover that
there's a fundamental limit on some
information processing task this puts a
limit a physical constraint on every
possible embodiment of that information
so information theory is really
Universal and it cross cuts across
physics so you could be studying say
electronic correlation in a piece of
superconductor and you discover a new
information pattern there and you can
transpose this information pattern to
something like a black hole and learn
entire new new physics there so and I'm
not just saying that because that
example I just gave was one of the
crowning achievement of our CFR program
in the past five year we took the
knowledge we have of quantum information
to shed new light on some of the deepest
questions in physics including the black
hole evaporation paradox this is where
the two pillars of modern physics
quantum mechanics and general relativity
collide so enough maybe about these
achievements so you all know that
information technologies have
transformed our society and very deep
way it's also transformed the way we
pursue knowledge and I believe that this
trend will continue I wouldn't be
surprised that soon the the information
theoretic perspective will affect many
if not all areas of science and maybe it
will even blur the boundary between
between scientific disciplines you know
the way we currently organize the
research is by saying oh you know this
is humanity this is life science this is
physical science but maybe in the future
we will organize research in terms of
what information processing is this
research concern with so here's here's
maybe some information some correlation
structure that shows up in the human
genome and the same pattern shows up in
economics so these people should be
working together because in terms of
information perspective they're working
on the same problem so you might think
that this
of idea sounds completely crazy but
that's precisely why I'm here so thank
you and have a good evening
[Applause]